بدايتنا غامضه مع الكثير من التساؤلات
وتنظيرات وراءها الحدث الاكبر هذا الشهر
الا وهو الزلزال نتحدث بالطابعه الزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب سوريا وتركيا ولكن ايضا
عن زلزال الاشاعات وتفسيرات والتاويلات
وحتى التوقعات البدايه كانت مع تغريده
العالم الهولندي الذي تنبا بالزلزال الذي
قبل وقوعي بثلاثه ايام تفسير العلماء ذلك
بان الصدفه كانت في صفه
العالم او الدجال بحسب انقسام الناس حوله
والمفارقه تنبا بزلزال ثاني وهذا الزلزال
حصل بدوره
العالم الهولندي يقول انه يعتمد على تموضع
الكواكب من اجل توقع الزلازل وهي وسيله
غير معتمده علميا لكن اليوم لنتحدث فقط عن
التوقعات بل عن نظريات مؤامره غريبه
ومثيره يبدو ان الكثيرين وكالعاده يميلون
لتصديقها
انتشرت على شبكات التواصل عده تفسيرات
وتاويلات وتنبؤات لسبب وقوع الزلزال في
تركيا وسوريا ومن اشهرها ان الولايات
المتحده استخدمت اسلحتها الغامضه التي
يمكن احداث زلازل اصطناعيه بتعديل المجال
المغناطيسي للارض وعلى الطقس والمناخ
ويلقي البعض باللوم على تركيا في انشاء
السدود التي خلفت وراءها بحيرات تخزين
مياه عملاقه من المياه الجوفيه في باطن
الارض نظريه زعم انفجار قنبله نوويه صغيره
داخل غواصه الروسيه صغيره في اعماق البحر
المتوسط وهناك من يعتقد ان الزلزال وقع
نتيجه تجربه النوويه خاطئه داخل المشروع
النووي الروسي التركي في محطه اوكويو
النوويه التركيه لانتاج الطاقه الكهربائيه
[موسيقى]
على كل من القاهره ينضم الينا استاذ
الجيولوجيا في جامعه القاهره عباس
الشرقاوي اهلا بك دكتور عباس معانا في
الصباح العربيه الكثير من الاشاعات حامت
حول زلزال تركيا وسوريا نبدا بابرزها اولا
استخدام اسلحه لاحداث زلازل اصطناعيه بهدف
احداث التعديل المجال المغناطيسي للارض
جيولوجيا الى هذا منطقي
وكل الساده المشاهدين
الحقيقه يعني اذا تحدثنا عن الزلزال وان
يكون عمل صناعي هذا الزلزال قوي للغايه
وشدته بتصل الى حوالي 1000 قنبله نوويه من
قنابل هيروشيما وبالتالي لو كان هذا عمل
صناعي يبقى اذا قنبله او اتنين او عشره
لكن لما يبقى الف قنبله وهذا الزلزال
الضخم اللي حصل سته فبراير ادى الى ان
الكتله الاناضليه اللي هي بطول 1300 كيلو
متر وعرض 500 كيلو ان تندفع اتجاه البحر
المتوسط حوالي 8 كم فاذا القوه هائله اكبر
دكتور الزلزال اكبر من اي قنبله بشريه
الف مره اكبر يعني اكبر من هيروشيما الف
مره وايضا يعني كميه المتفجرات المطلوبه
لاحداث هذه الطاقه تعادل 50 مليون طن
متفكره طب يعني استاذ عباس
اليوم عم نقرا كثير من النظريات وكل يوم
يتم تداول نظريه غير عن الثانيه هل هذا
يعني بانه كلامك يضحك كل النظريات التي تم
الحديث عنها هل من يقرا التاريخ يعرف بان
هذه المنطقه اي اصلا منطقه نشطه للزلازل
نتحدث ان هناك
القوه التي حدثت في سته فبراير سبعه فاصل
ثمانيه وايضا سنه 99 سبعه فاصل سته اذا
المنطقه ليس بغريب عليها ان يحدث زلزال
بهذه القوه بالاضافه الى ان مراصد العالم
بالكامل رصدت هذا زلزال بهذه القوه وعلى
عمقه لان المحطات تستطيع تحديد بؤره
السلسله اللي هي تحت سق الارض ووجد ان هذه
الكوره تقع تحت سطح الارض من 10 الى 20
كيلومتر
للزلازل الرئيسيه اللي حدث اللي حدثت لان
في زلزال في زلزالين فوق السبعه وفي حوالي
اربع زلازل فوق السته اخرهم او الامس
زلزال سته وثلاثه من عشره فكل هذه زلات
رصدت انها تحت سطح الارض باكثر من عشره
كيلو الى 20 كيلو هذا ايضا يؤكد انه عدم
وجود انفجار سطحي لان مهما كان هناك ذكاء
عام صناعي بيبقى قريب من السطح وهل اكثر
يبقى كيلو او اتنين كيلو لكن على عشرين
كيلو بالاضافه الى ان الوميض اللي ظهروا
او البرق اللي حصل هناك بعض الزلازل يحدث
معك بهذا الشكل استاذ عباس هذا بالنسبه
للارض طيب من بين الاشاعات التي ترددت
انفجار قنبله نوويه صغيره داخل وساروسيه
في عمق البحر المتوسط هل النظريه النوويه
ايضا منطقيه
حددنا مراكز الزلازل وجدت انها بداخل
تركيا اكثر من 100 كيلو في الداخل يعني في
غازي عنتاب
وبالتالي
عن البحر المتوسط
هذا الكلام يعني غير صحيح طيب استاذ عباس
ذهب البعض الى الحديث عن مساله المياه
الجوفيه وكانه في انفجار للمياه من جوف
الارض جراء السدود التي تبنيها تركيا وهذه
من اكثر النظريات التي تم تداولها ايضا ما
تعليقك عليها
هو احنا بنقول السدود بتنشئ زلازل
بطبيعتها لان السد عباره عن جسم سواء
الركابي من الصخور او خرساني فهو وزن ثقيل
على القشره الارضيه هذا ده بالنسبه للجسم
السد نفسه والبحيره او خزان السد بيخزن
كميه من المياه وزن هذه المياه ايضا بيكون
يعني عبء على المنطقه لو شفنا مثلا على
على سبيل المثال صدق اتاتورك وهو اقرب سد
لمناطق الزلازل
بيخزن 49 مليار متر مكعب هذا الوزن معناه
49 مليار طن هذا وزن كبير على المنطقه
خاصه يعني في الهندسه عندما يوجد ثقل لاول
مره يؤدي الى هبوط الارض هدى بنشوفه عند
اقامه الكباري وغيره حتى علشان نضمن ان
الكباري لا تهبط بدرجه بنخلي الارض تهبط
الاول اثناء بنضع كتل من الخرسانات يمكن
تعادل مئات الاطنان لكي نضمن ان الارض
تهبط دلوقتي بدل ما تهبط في المستقبل لكن
لا نستطيع ان احنا نعمل كده مع السدود ان
احنا
خزان مثلا زي بحيره ناصر في مصر طولها 500
كيلو متر ومساحتها اكثر من 5000
لكي تهبط ولكن لما بتملك باللياء يحصل
الهبوط لازم ولكن اذا كانت المنطقه
الزلازل الضعيفه اما اذا كانت زي تركيا
وهي
محاضر
بفواصل ضخمه جدا بتفاصيلها عن بقيه
الصفائح الكهربائيه سواء الاسيويه او
الاوروبيه او الافريقيه او الكتله العربيه
في الجنوب التالي هي هي اصلا مناطق زلازل
ومناطق زلازل شديده فلما نعمل عليها تركيا
من اكبر الدول في العالم اللي بتنشئ سدود
عندها اكتر من 6
00 سنه وهذه السدود بتخزن اكتر من 650
مليار متر مربع لما نشوف منطقه الاناضول
جنوب الاناضول اللي فيها الزلازل هذه
المنطقه في مشروع
تم بالفئه عمل عشر سدود وجاري انشاء 12
اخرى هذه السدود بتخزن حاليا 120 مليار
متر مكعب وبالتالي يعني الارض في جنوب
الاناضول هناك كفالئ كبير اللي هو فارق
شرق الاناضول حدثت عليه الزلازل وما زالت
مستمره حتى اليوم بالتوابع مستمره وبشده
تقترب من
خمسه اختر من اربعه الى خمسه حتى اليوم
يمكن اليوم بقى حوالي 5 او 10 زلازل على
الاقل في الصباح اليوم وبالتالي المنطقه
ناشطه فمش محتاجه طب حتى نظريه السدود
ايضا مستبعده شكرا جزيلا من القاهره استاذ
جيولوجيا في جامعه القاهره عباس الشرقاوي
شكرا على هذه التوضيحات